something in my gut tells me either no
one's gonna care about this or I'm
really gonna regret talking about it so
I am a bit late to this topic by a
couple of weeks actually
but odd the thing was when what all this
initially broke it completely just flew
under my radar I wasn't even aware and
then after realizing what had gone on
and then the reaction to what had gone
on I was like I wonder if I should even
talk about that because I seem to be
not engendering myself very well to a
number of fandoms lately and do I want
to invite scrutiny from another but then
of my yeah hell with it so Thundercats
is getting a new show
it's called Thundercats roar and there
was announcement video showing some of
the footage including sort of looks like
the the opening credits sequence a
little bit of insight from behind the
scenes people and people seem to this
thing like the if you look at that
announcement video the down votes on it
are holy crap it's like I don't even
remember what it was but it was
something like twelve times what the up
votes are that is bad and I kind of I've
seen sort of two things come out of this
I've seen a stripe of fan
Thundercats fan I'm sure being very
upset by by the look and the feel and
the tone of this show and then I've seen
a response to that backlash which seemed
which I have seen it being portrayed
largely as all for the love of God shut
up and stop whining and as so it's often
the case I find myself falling in the
middle so allow me to attempt to
mitigate and bridge the gap and probably
end up mm ticking off both sides we'll
see
so yeah I mean you can look at this at
these images and you can check out that
announcement trailer if you if you
haven't if you know Thundercats at all
this is very very very very different
and so you know nasty response and then
basically quit whining response to that
nasty response and I'm gonna sort of
start with with what my intended
endpoint is gonna be somebody don't talk
myself out of it as I go and then I'll
fill in from there so that you're not
sitting around waiting for my conclusion
I do think the reaction is a little bit
overblown but I also don't think it is
I don't think a negative reaction is
completely unwarranted I do I do think
at least some of what I have seen seems
to be a little much but yeah I do get it
so how to fill this in so let's start
with just the the degree of the vitrail
it is because it is it is getting nasty
out there
fandom is becoming a really unpleasant
place lately like in general I'm not
even like singling out
Thundercats fans Oh in case you wanted
my own relationship to Thundercats I
enjoyed Thundercats as a kid I watched
the show not religiously but I did enjoy
it it was one of you know what I two or
three of what I would have considered my
favorite shows when I was I you know
younger than ten it was basically that
he-man the Real Ghostbusters I had a
decent number of the toys I enjoy
Thundercats I'm not a massive fan though
I don't I don't read the comics I didn't
see more than an episode of the revived
series from I believe it was 2011 like
I'm not a hardcore fan on this I'm a
very casual and nostalgic family oh yeah
I remember that sort of things that's
that's sort of my standing where I'm at
and reboots are a strange beast and we
do as fans have a tendency to get
overworked up
about them especially when it comes to
something that has been has already been
rebooted more than once like when it's
the first time something's being
rebooted again I'm not saying that
shouting about it is still necessarily
the best response but I think the
trepidation is a little bit more
warranted in that case because you know
an initial go at a reboot if it tanks
that could be it and you could never get
another bite of the Apple or if it
succeeds but is a really poor
representation of what the thing was
before then it could end up superseding
the original and if you've loved the
original that can suck that was sort of
a lot of my issues going in on the 2016
Ghostbusters movie my issue with it was
the fact that it was not in continuity
it was a reboot it was erasing the old
stuff and they were and I mean sony sony
wants to franchise desperately they
wanted to build the new franchise and
basically make this new thing
Ghostbusters and pretend like the old
thing didn't happen and that rubbed me
the wrong way so I get that but I mean
at the same time even with the reboot
that is the the first reboot on
something which this isn't for the
record but even when it is you know it
doesn't only metaphorically does it
erase the old stuff and and it can be
frustrating it can be infuriating it can
feel like nobody cares but you and that
is that's not a fun place to be and it's
easy for that to lead to anger I think
it's important to keep that in check
however but in terms of looking at this
like this this is a massive massive
massive departure for Thundercats it's
not one that I think is as out of the
blue as people presume though because
let's look back at that original
Thundercats cartoon it was a mix of
sincerity and goofiness because you know
you had characters facing down some
impressively realized threats and at
times the stakes feeling very genuine
but then on the other hand you
had snarf and the lower bills or
whatever they were and wilykit and
wilykat and you know the goofing around
and that you know always ending on a
joke and a laugh and you know there was
a silliness to it it was a balance of
those two things and when I point this
out the silliest I'm not mocking at this
part of what it was it was part of the
appeal was part of the fun it's fairly
standard for the time actually but you
look at the first reboot the 2011 reboot
and that stripped out the silly and
tried to go completely serious and
regardless of whether you watched it or
not regardless of whether you liked it
or not it didn't do well ratings wise it
didn't do enough to keep going for very
long in the candidate so when a licence
holder is looking at a property they go
boy this is sometimes serious sometimes
goofy and you go in all in and you're
like well we don't just want to try and
literally do the same thing again
because then we might as well just
revive the series but we're never gonna
make anybody happy with that because
will either be accused of screwing up
the cannon or will be accused of just
being overly celebratory masturbatory
about the whole thing so we are gonna do
a reboot so what we need to do our own
flavour so how do we shift well first
time we tried going completely dead
serious going all in on how serious it
was that didn't work heck let's do the
other side let's go all in on the goofy
aspect then drop the more serious
element now that mayst honestly still be
a bad idea but I at least feel like I
can follow the logic as to why this is
being taken as an approach and I don't
think it's necessarily an invalid
approach I mean look there are plenty of
things that I think are bad ideas and
sometimes those bad ideas actually turn
out to work I think you can try just
about anything you want you do have to
sometimes think about what you're what
you're gonna be in for when you do try
it and maybe decide is it worth it for
for the potential wrath of
to invoke Hummer going this direction I
think some more places could stand to
think about that sometimes but the thing
is and here's the one other thing
because you know there's there's plenty
of franchises that are rebooted over and
over and over again and sometimes when
there's outcry to the reboot like I
don't get it
like I I don't fully get the outcry
against Teen Titans go I understand
fans of the earlier Teen Titans cartoon
being annoyed that that was not brought
back I understand that frustration but
Teen Titans go is its own thing it's not
really trying to be the earlier version
of Teen Titans it is doing very much its
own thing and I think it's fine and I
feel that that's kind of what they're
got what they seem to be trying for with
this new Thundercats it's not trying to
be the old thing it is trying to do
something new using those elements using
those pieces I'll never understand what
there's ever outcry against any new
version of the Ninja Turtles even when
they suck and sometimes they do but when
there's pre-emptive outcry like before
it's even there like look I'm not sure
there's there is anything that has been
rebooted rejiggered andrey stylized as
often as ninja turtles has so if you
don't like this version wait five years
you'll have another one it's like that
one I will never get but there is
another element at play and it's
something that I don't think I've ever
seen talked about a brought up in the
discussion of reboost particularly
things that have been either rebooted of
translated to more than one medium
generally speaking the original medium
in which the work is presented in is
considered to be the definitive medium
of the work so Ghostbusters the the 2016
Ghostbusters went out the first one to
have a female Ghostbuster I mean setting
aside the fact that
Janene was allowed to be Ghostbuster in
the Real Ghostbusters cartoons there was
the cartoon extreme Ghostbusters which
had a prominent female character but
nobody cared because that's a cartoon
this is a movie franchise as far as
people are concerned and you at least
from my perspective when they do
something weird and wonky with comic
book characters and either a television
or a film adaptation that to me is not
as egregious as screwing the character
up in the comics themselves because
that's their home turf that's their
medium that's the quote-unquote real
version that everything else derives
from so when we're talking Thundercats I
think that comes into play because
Thundercats is a TV show first it was
actually one of the few that was
existing as a fiim was being worked on
before the toy line even started the toy
line wasn't first although you can't see
how the fact that they knew they were
gonna have a toy line was influencing
the show so you know there's still a
little bit of the snake eating its own
tail there but it was still a TV show
first that's what it is first and
foremost so when you present something
so radical in the same medium that the
work was originally presented in I think
that has a tendency to draw more ire I
think if I think if Thundercats war was
a webcomic or web series a webtoon
series I there will be some people still
annoyed I don't think it would be nearly
as loud as it is right now because it's
being presented in the medium that is
the definitive Thundercats medium and
that that makes the offense I think feel
greater for people who don't like the
look of this and I actually haven't
really passed judgment on the look of
this thing and even though I've said I
think it's a perfectly valid approach I
think the look is very generic at this
point it's kind of it's it's sort of a
stalk look it's a stalk Steven universe
you know star versus the forces of evil
Adventure Time kind of look and nothing
against those but I mean though that
aesthetic was once unique seeing it just
slapped onto an existing franchise is
really weird to me and kind of
off-putting so but that said I mean the
the speed of the jokes the fluidity of
the animation they're putting some
decent work into this I think at least
from what little I can see and reboots
really are a fraud medium or a fraud
kind of project to be doing especially
when you're talking about a nostalgic
property and obviously the safer thing
to do is to do something where maybe
you're altering the visual look but
you're very much and like maybe some of
the pacing bringing it up to more
current standards but you're keeping the
heart of it virtually the same I mean
that's what the ducktales reboot is
doing and that thing is awesome it
really is and so doing something that is
much more this complete and from the you
know from the ground up thing like it's
so it is so vastly different it almost
feels like a Robot Chicken sketch that
that might be a step too far and I get
why people are angry I again the level
of anger I've seen at least in a few
places does strike me as a bit much
because look guys it if this if this
dummy first of all if you don't want to
watch it don't but it if it is that bad
then it'll probably be short-lived if it
does work
honestly that might give you a better
shot at getting a version of Thundercats
that you want because it'll show that
the brand is still viable and maybe
it'll revive something like the attempts
to do a movie version of Thundercats
that has been something that keeps
cycling back up and the right shuffle
around but nobody moves on it over and
over and over again I think because no
one's certain the viability of the
property anymore I think there's
probably people waiting in the wings who
would love to do a more serious take of
Thundercats but they already tried
one of those and it didn't work so this
is a way to keep the license alive and
viable because otherwise it's just gonna
be the occasional series of comic books
which I don't even know if those are
currently running right now I expect so
probably but probably at IDW but I
actually don't know I should have
checked that crap I need to do research
sometimes but I I don't like to do it it
gives me a rash I have a note from my
doctor but you know comic book tie-ins
to these things they kind of keep them
limping on but they don't revitalize a
flagging intellectual property a
flagging IP a show could and if it
proves that this is a property that can
still bring in interest and money then
maybe finally some of the other things
could be done with it again or they may
decide oh it's you know this the goofy
version is the only version they just
double or triple down on that who knows
it could it could go any number of way
guys but it does not necessarily have to
be a death knell even if even if you
don't like it um but at the same time
I'm not telling you you're wrong for
being upset I get it I've been there
myself with other franchises so I get it
but try and keep things in perspective
as best you can that's the best that I
can offer and while recognizing I have
not always been able to do that myself
so I never said I wasn't a hypocrite so
there you go folks my thoughts on
Thundercats roar what are your thoughts
whatever they are drop something down in
the comments let's talk about it there's
all this stuff to do so just like
subscribe support me on patreon if you
like this show and you want to support
it on patreon I should I should think
this outro out better you can buy
t-shirts follow me on Twitter whatever
links for all that stuff's down in the
description so until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]